salut, c'est Robert Deniro pour Brut, les gens
devraient s'exprimer, ils doivent le faire quand ils veulent que
les choses empirent, ils le feront
vraiment avec des manifestations de masse
[Musique]
c'est la diversité culturelle que nos
parents et ses grands-parents ont amenée en
Amérique qui fait la force de cette
nation  et nous pouvons tous être fiers de notre
héritage
[musique]
ils étaient, ils étaient très heureux qu'un
soutien pour tout ce que je voulais faire,
surtout si c'était dans les
arts, je pense qu'ils l'auraient fait, ils ne l'auraient pas fait,
ils n'auraient peut-être pas été  aussi
heureux si j'étais quelque chose qui ne l'était pas,
mais ils ne m'ont jamais encouragé ni
découragé de quelque manière que ce soit.
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant, je voyais Marty dans
le quartier où vivait Marty et je traînais
autour de lui et puis plus tard, nous  Je les ai
réunis peut-être dix ans plus tard et nous aurions
peut-être commencé à parler de Mean
Streets qu'il envisageait de faire
et c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que je sois un père dur
comme certains pères peuvent le faire.  mais je pense que
mes enfants pourraient être mauvais
[Musique]
le 11 septembre 2001, ma propre ville à
New York, mon propre quartier de New York
a été attaqué et nous leur avons lancé
le Tribeca Film Festival comme un
geste d'espoir, de résilience et de
combats
Je ne suis pas sûr de ce que je cherche, je suis
juste tu sais, je suis assis là à regarder
les films et ensuite nous trouverons une solution,
tu sais mais j'ai hâte de voir les
films, je ne suis pas inquiet mais je  Je
l'attends avec impatience
alors que le nom Dinero est synonyme de
dur à cuire, son véritable don est la
sensibilité qu'il apporte à chaque rôle.
[Musique]
Je me sens si profondément offensé par le
comportement de cette personne et par ce qu'il
a fait pour détruire l'Amérique.  ce sont les
institutions, je suis très très préoccupé
par ce qui se passe dans ce pays
avec quelqu'un comme Trump, vous regardez les
autres dictateurs, ils vous ressemblent beaucoup
maintenant, nous avons un président gangsta qui
défie la loi et ce n'est pas bon pour
nous, ça va  ça va ruiner ce
pays
[Musique]
toi